la solution à cette baisse d'immunité je
rappelle que les personnes qui sont
éligibles pour rappel aujourd'hui la
grande campagne de rappel le rap est une
deux trois quatre doses jusqu'où le
gouvernement pourrait-il aller pour
tenter de mettre fin au vide 19
multiplier les doses est il vraiment la
seule solution est inscrit ce qu'est
réponse dans facture
[Musique]
le but du vaccin rappelons le est avant
tout de protéger contre les formes
graves de la maladie et de limiter la
transmission du virus et non pas de
l'empêcher entièrement car aucun vaccin
n'offrent de protection intégrale à 100%
le but de cette troisième dose est donc
de venir à finir la vaccination initiale
a muté est devenu plus infectieux
rebooster le taux d'anticorps présent
dans le sang pour les personnes qui ont
reçu de premières doses l'immunité qu'on
a eue avec la primovaccination était
suffisante pour se prémunir la souche
originale telle qu'elle est sortie en
courant ou bien du var ayons alpha marie
paule kieny et sandrine sarrazin travail
toutes les deux à l'inserm elle nous
explique pourquoi cette dose de rappel
s'impose et jusqu'où cela pourrait aller
maintenant c'est assez clairement établi
que le taux d'anticorps qu'on a dans le
sang qui chute un peu on y six à neuf
mois qui suivent la deuxième dose comme
on est encore en pleine épidémie
al'approche de l'hiver vraiment
raisonnable de redonner un petit coup de
boost pour les vaccins réel message est
on est en train d'avoir quelque chose de
l'ordre de 6 mois pour les vaccins
inactivés chinois notamment sinovac les
rappels se font même déjà trois mois
après la prononciation donc c'est un
temps au conclut coup les deux études
les plus récentes sorties à la rentrée
l'une française et l'autre américaine
confirme d'ailleurs le besoin d'injecter
se rappelle presque un an après le
lancement de la campagne vaccinale les
vaccins de pfizer biotech moderna et
astrazeneca sont efficaces à plus de 90%
contre les formes graves du coc u19 et
ce jusqu'à au moins cinq mois après un
schéma complet les trois vaccins
continue donc bien de protéger contre le
risque de décès mais c'est la protection
contre le risque de contamination qui
diminue fortement en seulement quelques
mois entre février et octobre 2021
l'efficacité du vaccin contre le risque
d'infection a diminué de 88 % à 48 %
mais la vaccination est resté efficace
contre le risque de décès chez les
personnes qui ont été infectés pendant
l'émergence du variant delta
multiplier les doses de vaccin n'est pas
anodin bien au contraire par exemple
regardons la liste des onze vaccins
obligatoires en france voici le nombre
de doses requises pour chaque vaccin
pour acquérir une protection suffisante
contre la maladie le schéma deux doses
plus un rappel est le plus répandu
est en temps normal après l'injection de
ces doses il n'est plus nécessaire de
maintenir un niveau d'anticorps aussi
élevé dans le sang par exemple une fois
les vaccinations obligatoires fait à
l'enfance il est rare de faire un rappel
à l'âge adulte et lorsque le rappel
s'impose son rôle est de stimuler la
réponse immunitaire dit mémoire pour
recréer des anticorps qui avait disparu
mais dans le cas du colis de 19 il ne
s'agit pas tout à fait de faire appel à
notre mémoire immunitaire car le coc u19
et toulouse là on vient vraiment à la
fois intime et la réponse mémoire pour
qu'ils s'installent pour le futur de
manière durable mais on vient surtout
pour stimuler les globules blancs qui
frappe les anticorps là maintenant tout
de suite après la vaccination d'un gros
stimuler encore une fois pour avoir un
bon taux d'anticorps dans sont
donc dans le meilleur des mondes voici à
quoi ressemblerait le scénario le plus
idéal le plus simple pour être enfin
débarrassé du cold imaginons qu'on
conserve maintenant le variant delta
c'est lui qui s'établit qui devient ce
qu'on appelle endémiques comme pour tous
les autres virus contre lesquelles on se
vaccine contre l'enfance il ya pas de
raison de penser a priori qu'on devra
renouveler ses vaccinations et les
rappels aussi régulièrement que ça
peut-être que ce sera que tous les dix
ans ou tous les 15 ans comme le dtpolio
ou peut-être que ce sera jamais ce sera
suffisant il est possible que chez les
personnes qui ne sont ni à jenny vu les
reins beaucoup d'autres maisons un
schéma primo immunisation plus un rappel
soit suffisant pour un temps assez long
si par contre le virus continue de muter
alors chaque année à l'approché de
l'hiver comme la grippe une nouvelle
vaccination sera très probablement
fortement recommandée la vaccination de
la grippe qui est annuelle mais en fait
c'est pas un rappel qu'on fait chaque
lundi et chaque année on fait une
nouvelle vaccination parce qu'en effet
c'est un nouveau virus et si on arrive à
rians différence jacky d'air est bien
mais il faudrait une nouvelle
vaccination chaque il a alors qu'il
s'agisse d'une deux trois ou quatre
doses peu importe le nombre ce qui est
important de noter en tout cas c'est que
combiner les différents types de vaccin
n'est pas dangereux bien au contraire la
stimulation primaire qu'on envoie à
notre système immunitaire c'est toujours
la même chose avec quel véhicule on
l'amène que ce soit un vaccin est rennes
avec l'adn d'un à deauville adénovirus
finalement peu importe l'essentiel c'est
que la manière dont on stimule le
système immunitaire c'est via cette
protéine de spicules du virus peut très
bien imaginer d'avoir première année une
vaccination avec un vaccin est admise
âge et l'année d'après à voir une
vaccination avec un vaccin inactivé elle
a aidé après avec safura la fois
maximiser la réponse immunitaire puisque
ses différentes plateformes induisent
des réactionnaires un petit peu
différente c'est pas un problème du tout
voire même ça peut être ça peut
favoriser une bonne une bonne
immunisation
seules les études et le temps donc
pourront trancher et confirmer
l'efficacité d'un vaccin avec ou sans
rappel car pour chaque vaccin il faut
bien différencier son efficacité
potentielle de son efficacité réelle
l'efficacité potentielle d'un vaccin ce
calcul lorsque l'on mène des essais
cliniques entre deux groupes de
personnes complètement différent ceux
n'ayant pas reçu de vaccin ce qu'on
appelle le groupe placebo et ceux qui
ont reçu une ou deux doses l'efficacité
réelle du vaccin mesure donc à quel
point ils fonctionnent dans la vie
réelle et la réalité est souvent bien
plus compliqué à mesurer ou anticipées
est ce que cette protection va durer si
ya pas de formules mathématiques et
c'est à partir des études qu'on va faire
dans la vraie vie chez les gens qui ont
reçu le vaccin avant tout le monde qu'on
pourra du coup suivre l'évolution de la
protection et 10 rebonds mais maintenant
c'est le moment de refaire un rappel ou
pas en france par exemple avec le bcg le
vaccin qui protège la tuberculose ça
fait déjà plusieurs années qu on ne
vaccine plus systématiquement en tout
cas plus partout en france y est que
certaines régions de france qui sont
encore considérés comme des régions
potentiellement à risque on continue
avec ses enfants
que la stratégie vaccinale évolué au
cours du temps en fonction de ce qu'on
observe dans la vie réelle c'est tout à
fait comme un but